my roommate and stuff for that
um
but other than that so so you're no
longer on the street yeah
you were
you bounced around you were down in
south central for a while yeah
and you had a pimp or two in along the
way
um
about a year ago yeah
how was that experience
um
honestly
it wasn't my cup of tea you know what i
mean
um
i don't regret anything in my life you
know
but
i'm glad that i went through it so now i
can tell myself and
i can prove to myself that i'm better
than that you know
like i and why have a pimp whenever i'm
i can be
better off without one you know i mean
like i can be a better of a person
without one
because when you when you have like a
pimp or you have somebody
over you
it
takes a lot away from your personality
you know like
your freedom
like
the united states is meant to be free
right
so you're
you're free from uh fentanyl
yeah tell me about that oh my gosh just
i'm really proud of myself how'd you do
this
um
well i just started slowing down like i
was at a hundred dollars a day
and
i just started cutting myself down
slowly slowly slowly
and it's also because of the money issue
like i i haven't had enough money to
like pay for it and [ __ ] you know so
i've had i've like swindled myself down
and then i went from 100 a day to 30 a
day
and then from 30 to like
maybe a dub a day
and
now i'm
a week and a half sober but
that's a big milestone
yeah
i'm not naive enough to know you know
i'm
i know i know that you've replaced it
with something what have you replaced it
with weed weed i mean i'm still i'm
still smoking crystal but uh
yeah yeah so that's that's that's i can
stop whenever you know i just do it just
for something to do you know
like it's like everybody around me does
that and
i i push myself away from all the people
that do fentanyl
i'll say hi and [ __ ] to them but i don't
hang out with them or anything like that
anymore where do you stay down
um i stay in an apartment with one with
my roommate
um
it's it's a new it's new you know what i
mean like
it's not permanent you know of course
you know
but
for now it's like a sustainable
it's it's not like i have to worry about
anything you know
really
i don't know but now that you're doing
so well you know when i first met you
you were talking about getting a job and
yeah and all that i'm still waiting on
my id i'm trying to figure out how the
[ __ ] i'm i'm gonna get my id because
i'm from tennessee you know what i mean
um
[Music]
i've looked up different ways and stuff
i even went to the dmv
and
they told me i tried to take in the
voucher
and i filled it out and everything
whenever i took it they said that it
doesn't apply to me i was like
what do you mean it don't apply to me it
applies to everybody right and they said
only if you've had a california id
so
i'm still awaiting
somebody to help me get my id
um
man
when i can get my id i can get a job i
can sign up for my own [ __ ] housing
you know what i mean get my own
permanent housing
i can get food stamps
you know what i mean like i i can
actually i would be actually be able to
take care of myself
like i want to like i know i can you
know
i'm just being like held back because
i don't have a sustainable
um
money
like money coming to me you know it's
not probably because you don't have an
id
but food stamps and all that stuff oh my
gosh i can't wait till i get my id but
i'm still trying to find the proper help
for
that because i've asked people but
tell me about some of the friends you've
made since you've been down here
um
actually i haven't made no friends
um that's not surprising
the friends that i thought i did have i
came to realize that
they don't deserve to be in
that group of
imagination
you know
uh i don't have any friends
i don't want any friends
you know i'll say hi and bye or how have
you been or you know if i if you know
there were cool people or whatever but i
i've been trying to stay away from
not society but
especially downtown l.a down here
there's nothing but hustlers and
yeah they're either trying to pick you
up or they're trying to
get you to spare some change you know
like
how does
the neighborhoods you've been staying in
down like south central compared to skid
row
um
well on skid road there's a lot of
people that
don't want anything for themselves
honestly like i'm nobody to say [ __ ]
like that but i mean my my
my view on it is
these people down here they have
shelters they could go to they have
food stamps almost all of them have food
stamps they have
housing they have people that are
[ __ ] coming out to you like outreach
programs coming out
directly trying to get people off the
street and put into housing you know
what i mean like there's people out
there trying to help these people
and they're still continuing to live in
their own field you know laying on the
side of the [ __ ] street [ __ ] on
themselves and stuff some of them i
understand they might have like mental
problems and stuff but still
the help is there you know they're
choosing to be the way that they are
and it's it's it's
i don't understand it you know
but i can't i can't let myself
get distracted from that you know
what about south central south central
there's not so many people like on the
street on the street
like everybody's at least like in a in a
trailer or something or in a tent
they can also be very treacherous yeah
yeah it's a lot more um
i guess they're a lot more
out to get you in south central you know
like
you have to watch your back because the
person that you have the closest to you
that you think isn't gonna do [ __ ] to
you
um
are gonna be the ones that are gonna
turn
and do the most wicked [ __ ] to you that
you never thought
you know
um
and actually it will traumatize you you
know what i mean
um
especially because they like to hold
things over your head that you value
and that you've grown adapt to
and they like to to take it away from
you
and they're like haha [ __ ] if you want
to come if you want this you know you
got to come back with me
and it's like it's hard it's hard as
this decision you know
but
people down here
they honestly don't give a [ __ ]
like people in south central you know
like people down here they'll just bust
you up on the side of the head or some
[ __ ] if they have a problem with you
they won't
actually sit and think about
what's gonna [ __ ] you over
i don't know man it's just it's crazy
it's crazy it's crazy
but i'd rather be down here as a south
central
you know you'd rather be down here than
south central yeah
yeah i understand that
actually i'm i'm kind of confused you
know
on where i'm supposed to be in my life
and
i don't
know um
[Music]
i just want to want a normal
life you know
without worry
without depending on somebody
yeah well you're young yet you can do
anything you like
what's the most important thing you've
learned since you've been hanging out
in these rough neighborhoods
trust yourself 100
don't trust nobody else
you know
um
[Music]
you're gonna see some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
you know but you have to
learn from it
even though it might not be you that
went through whatever these people are
going through but you're there to
witness it
you
you just have to learn from somebody
else's experiences as well you know
[Music]
you have to not let
anybody around here or the environment
itself
throw you off track from what what
you're doing what you're supposed to do
you know
um there's a lot of temptation you know
but
you can't give in to it yeah
all right rachel well thank you so much
for coming back and sharing your story
thank you you look a lot better i'm glad
you're
mostly clean
clean from fentanyl which is one of the
worst things you can be addicted to
hope for the best you know i wish you
the best of luck thank you so much thank
you
you